all right this is not your typical
senior health insurance segment okay
your insurance agency is introducing us
to a company that is dedicated
to people small businesses and making
health care planning feel like
a friday take a look
friday health plans the name actually
comes it's the day of the week everybody
looks forward to
so it's a positive sound to health
insurance where people
not always like to listen or talk about
health insurance friday health plans is
a consumer driven purposely built for
the consumers who purchase their own
health insurance
and we try to make it more friendlier
more tech savvy
for those people who do purchase their
own insurance we are new to nevada
but we have been in colorado we
purchased a health insurance company a
50 year old company
and been servicing colorado for a period
of time
and now we're entering nevada for 2021
plan year
so we are partnered with hometown health
ppo network so we have a wide range of
primary care physicians ob gyns
urgent care clinics pediatricians spread
throughout the las vegas
valley on many of our plans primary care
visits are at a zero dollar co-payment
friday health plans
are affordable first of all they've come
in the market to be competitive number
one but also
with the tax credits available to people
this year it's important to bring that
good information into us
so that we can get them the most tax
credits available to them
from the federal government and again
coming into our mall
there's always an option the galleria
mall or the meadows mall
also they can call in or we also have on
our website a virtual
web virtual visit where they just click
on the button they go right into a live
virtual meeting with one of our brokers
that are on standby ready to help them
answer the questions and enroll in the
most affordable plan for them
what's very unique to our health plans
is that we have
a teledoc visits at a zero dollar
co-payment on
all of our plans before deductible
so you have access to see a doctor
virtually
through your smartphone your tablet 24
hours a day seven days a week wherever
you are
and it's not only just your primary care
you can also see mental health
counseling
in the comfort of your home own home too
i know there's many people with a
pandemic they just really don't want to
go
to a doctor's office and sit in a
waiting room and maybe
taking home something they didn't come
with all of our plans are aca compliant
affordable care act
and because of that we do not exclude
pre-existing conditions in addition to
we include a lot of preventative
services like mammograms
wellness checks and and so forth
so immunizations and and a lot of many
things that are already included in the
health plan
you can find information about friday
health plans you can talk to any broker
you can speak to chris if you'd like
you can also speak to nevada health link
or go to nevadahealthlink.com
it's available there as well as our
website fridayhealthplans.com
open enrollment ends on january 15th of
2021 for more information visit your
insurance company at meadows mall or the
galleria mall you can also call that
number right there on your screen
or visit the website y i a lv
dot com we'll be right back